oui on parle tout de suite de donald
trump et son défilé des chars sur
l'esplanade du mall à washington des
avions dans les airs c'est donc cette
parade pour l'independence day c'est la
première du genre et le président
américain est très enthousiaste sur
twitter ses adversaires un peu moins on
a récolté enfin en tout cas life qu'il a
fait pour nous quelques réactions de
passants à washington alors bertrand
perri on doit être fier finalement que
les américains nous empreinte notre 14
juillet bah on doit être d'autant plus
fier que semble-t-il trump explique
qu'il a eu l'idée de cette parade qui
est totalement inédite en effet aux
états unis lorsqu'il est venu au 14
juillet a invité par le président macron
et donc on peut être fier de cette cette
réplique malgré tout on ne peut pas
échapper au constat que tout cela relève
d'une manoeuvre électorale à gros sabots
puisque le président trump vient
d'annoncer à orlando cette semaine qu'il
était candidat à sa succession il va
évidemment jouer 2
son statut de président pour essayer au
bénéfice de cette démonstration de force
de jouer aussi le rôle du candidat on
revient à un test sur les thèmes de
campagne qu'il a déjà esquissé
mais évidemment il ya un mélange des
genres entre le président et candidat
qui est assez criant dans l'organisation
de ce défilé mais vous disiez il l'avait
déjà annoncé à peine à betty quitté le
défilé du 14 juillet à 2 heures donc
cela à ce moment là il n'était pas
encore candidat à sa réélection plus
possible et pas beaucoup de doutes sur
le fait qu'il briguerait un second
mandat
mais effectivement il ya des invitations
qui ont été données aux partisans de son
de son camp il ya au grands donateurs
sont invités à la parade
c'est une manoeuvre électorale un peu
grossière je pense que rien est innocent
quand on rentre en période électorale
cela dit que je remarque dès que ça
touche trump et il aider
il est convenu que ce n'est pas bien on
dit parade quand quand parade et voilà
tout est du registre d'ailleurs j'ai
remarqué en général des gallinacés il
fait le coq qui il est il
il est là il parade comme un paon
écoutez quand marc emmanuel macron
regarde son défilé il part est pas il
est fier de son art mais je crois tout
le monde est d'accord donc peut-être que
donald trump possible vous le disiez je
croyais je crois qu'il avait dit à
l'issue du 14 juillet je veux le même
d'une façon très trump est ce qu est en
effet on voit qu'il ya des avions de
chasse qui
ressemble un petit peu à la patrouille
de france dans l'air il y à un certain
nombre de choses tout à fait similaire
au 14 juillet dire que c'est tout à fait
neutre dans sa compagne électorale
non mais un enfant de 4 ans est bien que
n'importe qui d'autre à sa place
auraient réfléchi à la façon là mais la
lame la meilleure de se mettre en avant
dans ce genre d'événement il me semble
que c'est un processus un peu un peu
artificielle qu'on lui fait la justice
suite je me souviens que les verts
avaient un moment exprimé un voeu pour
que l'on supprime le défilé militaire du
14 juillet je me rappelle que c'était
lorsque eva joly donc avant la campagne
présidentielle de 2012 donc en 2011
avait dit qu'en norvège par exemple un
défilé du 14-juillet militaire aurait
été totalement anti culturel eagle est
donc elle avait plaidé pour un défilé
pacifique
donc là ce qui est très intéressant
effectivement j'avais presque oublié ce
souvenir à l'époque je m'étais dit mais
qu'est ce qui se passe là on peut pas
importer une culture penser moi je dis
non moi je m'étais dit que c'était un
c'était une erreur du candidat de la
candidate eva joly parce que on n'était
pas en norvège et j'aurais tendance à
reproduire le même raisonnement
aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'on n'est pas
en france on n'est pas à paris ou à
washington
et d'ailleurs même géographiquement
c'est très compliqué d'organiser un
défilé militaire
lorsqu'on regarde les choses ce sera pas
du tout l'équivalent de la démonstration
de force voilà habib donc la chance et
il faut laisser les chars statique et
puis on voit mais on voit bien que c'est
clairement un acte électoral alors que
nous c'est pas un acte électoral le
défilé du 14 juillet pourquoi parce que
ça clive en fait dans les témoignages
que vous avez montré il ya ceux qui
disent donald trump est un génie et il
le pense depuis qu'il a été élu et puis
il ya ceux qui n'aiment pas donald trump
donc par rapport à ce que vous venez de
dire vous avez raison en fait aux
etats-unis comme en france dès qu'il
s'agit de donald trump
il ya les pour et les contre et quelque
part cet acte là va encore renforcer les
deux camps donc c'est fait pour c'est un
acte ii c'est un acte électoral et on
peut regretter qu'on soit de droite de
gauche ou trump ont dit en titre up
qu'une fête nationale sont récupérées
comme un acte électoral je pense que
c'est un cas finalement
en tout cas on vers nice est en france
et on sent que y'a attendant on a devant
lens on a tendance à dire j'ai fait un
plus beaux défilés de vous il n'ya pas
que ça parce qu'il ya eu 2 il ya eu des
polémiques autour des derniers 14
juillet par exemple quand des équipes
étrangères ou sur les invitations mais
même sur l'opportunité de faire défiler
des troupes étrangères qui a pas été
bien perçue à droite un exemple dont on
sait le faire kadhafi qui alors ça
c'était c'était pour les esprits
parmi les invités mais on voit bien que
ces trois qui sert allemand soit je
disais ça rappelle des mauvais souvenirs
à certains
enfin là là là on passe d'une
manifestation comme ça a été dit
apolitique et pacifique à quelque chose
de plus guerrier donc quelque part c'est
l'attitude guerrière de donald trump qui
rentrent en candidature et et voilà et
de toute façon il a une étude guerrière
systématique dans ses tweets vis-à-vis
de la chine vis-à-vis de l'europe ou
lorsqu'il dit que finalement ils
préfèrent le break site à l'union
européenne enfin il ya quelque chose de
très guerrier et donc c'est le symbole
même de ce qu'est donald trump marina il
ya un autre argument qui vaut ce qu'il
vaut mais c'est de certains américains
lisent finalement ça coûterait cher et
on ferait mieux c'est parce que je crois
que le budget en question pour
washington est pris sur le celui des
parcs nationaux
une partie ne sauf qu'on connaît pas le
budget de la fête telle qu'elle est
prévue cette année par donald trump car
feu d'artifice qui dure deux fois qu'il
va durer deux fois plus longtemps que
qu'à l'accoutumée bah oui mais c'est
donald poil il est plein de plus tous
donc fait mieux donc oui moi combien ça
coûte et franchement à la limite c'est
un faux débat ça ne s'est pas c'est pas
vrai parce que quand bien même cela
coûterait 100 millions de dollars qui
était le montant d'une fait d'une
célébration du 11 novembre à laquelle
avait pensé donald trump et qui avait
été annulé quand on avait justement
connu le montant du budget de
l'organisation
quand bien même ce serait 100 millions
par rapport à l'ampleur du déficit
américain
pan une toute façon je pense que donald
trump qui se considère comme étant le
meilleur business man qui n'a jamais été
élu la td états unis et que comme il
faut rendre à l'amérique sa prestance
d'avant franchement ça les vaut bien ses
illustres à thiviers aussi l'ambivalence
du rapport entre les américains à leurs
armes et ça que nous pour d'autres faits
nationale rituellement ont fait un
défilé militaire
alors que eux qui ont les vétérans qui
ont un culte quasiment de leurs
militaires précisément n'ont pas cette
tradition du défilé militaire
qu'il faut un trump effectivement qui
est toujours si on leur hygiène guerrier
pour restaurer ou en tout cas instauré
puisque je vois que le dernier il ya
plusieurs dizaines d'années à un défilé
militaire qui somme toute chez nous
alors qu'on a un rapport avec l'art mais
on n'a même plus de conscription assez
de distance le lien armée nation est
quelque chose d'assez distendus et bien
malgré tout les quelque chose à laquelle
quelque chose auquel on n'échappe à ces
le défilé militaire du 14 juillet sept
mois je suis pas tout à fait d'accord
sur le lien armée nation je crois qu'au
contraire il et il est excellent
actuellement et je crois que s'il ya
quelque chose qui impressionne les
américains en fauve dans parce que la
france peut produire n'est pas grand
chose un disons le et bien c'est
peut-être l'armée parce que précisément
quand licence sur les mêmes théâtre
d'opérations les français sont souvent
devant au contact ils ont un meilleur
rapport avec les populations ils savent
mieux se fondre en général ça se passe
très bien entre les américains et les
soldats américains et des soldats
français
on se souvient d'ailleurs qu'avec sa
façon là encore traître pesc de parler
là après le burkina faso de pression du
burkina façon il avait dit good job les
frenchies et je crois que si trump a
peut-être un une once de l'admiration
pour quelque chose de français c'est
peut-être pour l'armée donc
réjouissons nous de cela de nous pour
une fois que nous impressionnant le
président des états unis moi j'ai
tendance à me dire que c'est c'est
plutôt une bonne chose ou pas de valtice
alors se doit par les chauffeurs
discours il devrait s'intituler si j'ai
bien regardé salut à l'amérique alors on
peut tous maintenant là dedans mais on
ne revient pas et sans doute est ce que
vous demandez at-il raison donald trump
d'organiser cette parade militaire pour
la fête nationale oui à deux tiers
d'entre vous soient sentiments sont
exactement donc vous êtes plutôt
favorables alors nicole qui rebondit sur
nos échanges à propos de la récupération
politique ou non du 14 juillet nous
demande comme accro on descend les
champs sur le command car en paradant
n'est ce pas électoraliste réponse à
nicole ici je pense que c'est
présidentialiste après les états unis
comme la france ont le culte quelque
part d'un homme fort donc la question
c'est est-ce que cette foire présente
semble de la nation ou est-ce que là ils
représentent que je disais tout à
l'heure un peu en forme de boutade son
america lui et par rapport à ce que
disait marc sur la question de combien
ça coûte
moi je trouve ça très intéressant parce
que là ça fait aussi partie de la
culture américaine qui est une culture
où la présence de l'état la question des
finances publiques du déficit abyssal et
quelque chose qui quelque part et est -
enfin - partie du contrat entre les
citoyens et et donc combien ça coûte ça
peut être une question plus ennuyeuse
aux états unis même si c'est une goutte
d'eau que en france en france on
considère ça comme tout à fait normal
que le défilé du 14-juillet coûte très
cher les recoins du passé mon temps et
on est en demande jugée et si vous
interrogez un français ce qui veut dire
combien ça coûte le défilé du 14 juillet
tout le monde se foutra ta gueule mais
en revanche aux états unis poser cette
question sur l'utilisation des finances
publiques
c'est un sujet important et macro quand
ils défilent il exerce aussi son rôle
institutionnel de chef des armées donc
bien sûr qu'il ya qu à côté politique
mais il ya aussi le rôle constitutionnel
de chef des armées et camry yaris fillon
veut dire aussi parce que il le sait que
les derniers événements qui ont fédéré
en france qui ont fait l'unité même en
pleine crise des gilet jaune au moment
où elle était au plus fort et bien c'est
quand il ya eu un sacrifice militaire je
parlais du burkina faso un jeu mais il y
en a eu d'autres ya eu un jeune médecin
militaire qui a vécu dans la mare à
chaque fois il ya un moment comment dire
d'union sacrée de trêve dans leur dans
cette espèce de de france à cherré
archipel 10 et pour reprendre
l'expression du rhum fourquet donc c'est
vrai que je pense qu'un président de la
république un peu futés se dit et bien
en mettant à côté dans le dans la
voiture qui qui remontent les champs
elysées il rejaillit sur lui ruisselle
un petit peu de cette unité nationale
retrouvée ce ciment qui quiz ça date de
quand le défilé
je me suis posé la question j'ai été
regardé je dois dire s'il s'agit d'un
déficit moyen parce que moi je ne vais
pas leur dire que l'otan ces deux en
fait ça a été remis ces 1881 le défilé
en corse avait pas lieu sur les
champs-elysées c'était après la défaite
de 1870 pour prouver que l'art
et ça a d'abord eu lieu du côté de
longchamp sur l'hippodrome de longchamp
fin dans ces coins là qu'ils étaient
encore et puis ensuite sur les champs
elysées et bien plus tard
depuis quand alors je savais que c'est
après la première guerre mondiale
oui aussi en fait c'est la session de
rattrapage alors le mercosur ça ça va
être pour vous le marque donc depuis le
week-end dernier la contestation monte
sur ce d'accords de libre échange signé
entre l'union européenne et les quatre
pays d'amérique du sud qui forment le
mercosur
c'est un accord dont on n'a pas fini de
parler ici même d'ailleurs d'un point de
vue pas plus tard que mardi dernier
on essayait de se demander quel était un
peu les conditions et on avait du mal il
faut bien l'avouer à répondre à une
question peut-être plus global plus
globales restent ouvertes c'est ce type
2 traités qui va concerner quelque 770
millions de personnes et un quart du pib
mondial
est ce bien raisonnable aujourd'hui
faut-il en permanence exporter davantage
au contraire arrêter cette course la
mondialisation le président français qui
sent bien la contestation monte a dit
ceci c'était mardi pendant trop
longtemps il y a une naïveté libre
échangiste qui a parfois en effet été
complètement contradictoire avec
l'ambition climatique et qui a
déséquilibré des secteurs c'est terminé
mais il ne faut pas non plus qu'il y ait
de l'autre côté une espèce de néo
protectionnisme qui s'installe en disant
c'est l'autre est forcément mauvais on
n'a pas tout de suite mais on écoute
avant l'ancien premier ministre
dominique de villepin alors je lui
justement il dit on ne peut plus signer
ce type 2 traités comme on le faisait
avant le libre échange peut apporter un
certain nombre de réponses notamment aux
économies les moins développés donc je
pense que nier aujourd'hui les effets du
libre échange ne me paraît pas
correspondre à une réalité néanmoins on
ne peut pas faire comme avant ce n'est
pas n'importe quel libre échange qui est
acceptable
c'est un libre échange maîtriser
organisé est garanti alors
fini le temps du libre échangisme bea ne
serait ce que pour des questions
environnementales
oui et parce que l'évolution la société
est telle qu'aujourd'hui les peuples
n'accepte plus qu'ils acceptaient avant
route du moins ce sur quoi ils fermaient
les yeux avant je pense aux conditions
climatiques aux conditions effectivement
environnementales aux conditions
sociales au delà des simples conditions
commerciales donc oui on peut plus
traiter faire des traités de libre
échange comme on le faisait à rien ils
ont eu un train de retard en parce qu'il
a été négocié pendant vingt ans le texte
tel qu'il a été signé n'est pas celui
qui était qu'elle est en discussion il
ya une vingtaine d'années donc il ya un
certain nombre de contreparties
effectivement qu'on ne connaît pas ou
dont on n'est pas capable nîmes s'est en
tout cas moi j'en suis pas capable
aujourd'hui et j'ai met au défi
quiconque de dire oui ou non de dire est
ce qu'elle n'aurait elle n'a pas
formellement non plus le texte il faut
qu'il soit ratifié il faut qu'il soit
discuté il ya des cinq hommes pour un
texte de loi
ça renvoie à d'autres discussions sud et
de précision précisions ultérieures
donc c'est très compliqué en vérité on
juge aujourd'hui où on se positionne par
rapport à un texte d'ensemble un
équilibre d'ensemble mais dont on ne
connaît pas on connaît ni les finalités
ni les appendices donc c'est vrai que
c'est assez compliqué et ça devient
quasiment aujourd'hui dans société
contemporaine
un débat idéologique pour contre sans
nuance cap accusent elles vous êtes
favorable mais reçoit déjà sur le sur le
plan général ce qui ma fille et moi être
mon opinion personnelle de nom mais cela
dit ce qui m'a ce qui me
m'interpelle comme on dit maintenant
c'est de voir emmanuel macron d'hier
mardi être un peu d'allant même temps
alors que la veille vous me direz
qu'avec les imbéciles qui ne changent
pas d'avis mais la veille il analysé
extrêmement favorable moi ce qui
m'étonne c'est que finalement les
résultats des deux dernières élections
européennes ont montré deux choses que
les gens voulaient plus de frontières
plus de souverainisme plus de protection
peut dire ça comme on veut et plus
d'écologie et là ce qui est sûr c'est
que le mercosur ce ne donne ni l'un ni
l'autre
donc c'est un peu curieux c'est vrai
qu'on n'a pas l'accord dans sa totalité
néanmoins ça met en exergue par les
réactions ce dont les gens ne veulent
plus et ils ne veulent plus de ce libre
échangisme de ce libre échange qui
notamment fait de l'agriculture
l'éternel variable d'ajustement pour
d'autres industries
donc ça les agriculteurs on passe notre
temps à dire qu'on va les défendre mais
avec ce type d'accord quand même un
importé du boeuf en france il faut y
aller avec cet accord que ce que nous
savons aujourd'hui oui alors on va en
importer moins et le seul problème et on
ne sait tous c'est que les normes là bas
en matière phytosanitaire sont pas
d'accord c'est un accord il ya les non
financés non ne pouvez pas nous dire non
mais là pour le nom est là pour le coup
il ya des normes phytosanitaires en
europe qui interdisent l'importation de
territoire son désir elle vérifie vous
avez la réforme et la veille
voilà ça on paye des impôts il ya des
fonctionnaires qu'ils soient français ou
européens ou dans les autres pays qui
sont la cour en appliquant les règles
vont aller il faut encore faut-il et une
bonne volonté mais pas plus hier
qu'aujourd'hui du ps demain excellent
hard énorme et il gagne et on me dit
c'est comme si vous me disiez m'a
finalement ce traité ne va rien changer
en la matière sur les importations de
tous les importations je suis désolé sur
l'importation de bovins difficultés et
et de volaille c'est vrai ce que ça va
changer c'est pour les agriculteurs du
mercosur qui vont augmenter leurs marges
parce que des quotas ont été fixés qui
prévoit d'importer moins de viande
bovine de viandes volailles que ce qu'on
importe aujourd'hui simplement eux
gagneront plus d'argent parce que les
droits de douane moins stressés donc sur
le sur le côté invasif de de
l'agriculture du mercosur de d'amérique
latine amérique du sud non oui mais
alors ça monte parce qu'un vase
il faut vous jouer un petit peu sur les
mots mais sur le côté qualitatif qui est
qui qui est lié aussi à la au prix à la
façon dont ce sera vendu on demande à
nos agriculteurs plus de qualité tant en
termes de goût qu en terme d'écologie et
keira vérifier moi j'ai encore une fois
je le répète regarde on fait un tour de
table
et puis on parle dans le détail déjà
lucile schmid sur le côté on l'a évoqué
l'écologie la contradiction avec ce
conte régime simplement on va faire
faire des kilomètres à des marchandises
alors qu'on demande de produire local et
de se restreindre sur nos déplacements
l'ofas oui dans les lois diverses et
variées oui un sujet d'empreinte
écologique alors est il ya autre chose
qui est important à souligner c'est que
la commission européenne a un pouvoir en
fait qui lui est délégué en matière de
commerce international et donc elle a un
mandat et souvent c'est un monde à
tracer vague pour la négociation de ces
accords de libre-échange donc c'est une
grande tradition européenne est là
dessus c'est intéressant ce que dit
dominique de villepin avec lequel je
suis assez d'accord
en l'occurrence qui est que évidemment
on peut plus faire du libre échange
comme avant il ya l'aspect
environnemental mais il ya aussi
évidemment le fait que nous on souhaite
transformer notre propre agriculture
c'est à dire qu'on fixe des contraintes
à nos agriculteurs qui sont des
contraintes beaucoup plus forte
on a transformé la pac par exemple ce
que dit marc sur le fait que c'est pas
le même accord de libre échange qui
avait un temps mais la pac n'est pas là
même qui a 20 ans et donc les
contraintes sont extrêmement fortes
notamment en ce qui concerne les
éleveurs qui souffrent énormément
aujourd'hui qui s'offre aussi sur la
production de produits laitiers etc et
on sait que déjà il ya un problème
d'asymétrie effectivement entre les
importations venues de ces pays et la
production de viande
donc en fait en garantissant des quotas
d'une certaine manière on reconnaît
qu'il peut y avoir à symétrie donc moi
je trouve que ça pose un problème de
principe et ce qui est très intéressant
c'est que les agriculteurs qui était
présent sur un grand ensemble listes
européennes ont tous dit la même chose
et les écologistes qui était aussi
présent sur un grand champion de
l'histoire au pays c'est assez drôle de
se trouver cette les agriculteurs écolo
mr combat couesque agriculteurs
écologistes se retrouvent ensemble parce
que les agriculteurs sont soumis donc à
ces contraintes de transformation qui
sont immenses parce que l'alimentation
c'est un sujet à la fois de consommation
et un sujet économique et donc c'est là
dessus
pendant d'un accord de libre échange
mais j'ai transformation et les anciens
jeunes avouent rien et aimer ce que je
dis je dis c'est bien j'ai un sentiment
de déni démocratique qu'une fois les
élections passées la commission europe
se dépêchent de finaliser donc c'est
fait ratifié après pas le bouge pas oui
mais concernant on est dans un point
aveugle démocratique ça arrive et je
pense que ça accentue encore les
réactions avec l'impression que le
résultat des élections européennes n'est
pas respectée de chaussures sur l'accord
la première c'est qu'on est
effectivement au tout début et qui
d'ailleurs un processus de ratification
qui va être extrêmement long et qu'il
faut l'unanimité
donc on est déjà très loin du de la mise
en oeuvre de l'accord quand bien même il
serait ratifié son caractère
contraignant le même pose problème on
peut considérer certains considèrent on
regarde les extraits que nous avons de
cet accord qui les normands facultatif
et que en réalité il n'a aucun impact
sur l'environnement
les anciens parce qu'il ya un nom qu'on
n'a pas à prononcer keable sonar ou
parce que tout de même tous se
cristallise autour de ça on fait un
accord nous européens avec quatre pays
donc l'argentine le paraguay l'uruguay
et le brésil avec boys maroc est quand
même un ovni politique qui nous dit que
la défense